this guy is a drug dealer it may not
look like it but i deal in drugs drugs
you want them i got them drugs you need
drugs i seed out into the world i grow
from seeds i don't do drugs myself i
don't use what i grow i don't grow i
don't um there's a saying for that this
is terrible lexi and fix this so it's
all better or just start it over please
hi my name is markiplier and i've never
done drugs
that you know
of my name is markiplier and this is
drug dealer simulator have you ever
wanted to deal with drugs not do them
that would be illegal also is dealing
drugs illegal apparently but this is
drug dealer simulator where you can
deal drugs i don't condone any of this
so like many of the simulator games that
i've played in the past it's going to be
a completely realistic experience that's
going to allow me to truly step into the
world of dealing drugs
[Music]
oh
kind of cool
whoa
i like the style
yeah and [ __ ] you two
so here we are
the adventure is hot
the big question is is this my story or
your story same thing let's find out
together shall we pretty much
got that blunt handy no
this is the other path that you can take
you know when you go to a job fair
you've got like engineering school
you've got like streamer life simulator
and then you've got drug dealer
simulator uh
hello yo hope you're up
i would let you sleep yesterday off but
i have some trouble some [ __ ] to
attend to and it can't wait i'm waiting
for you at the main square close to my
place sober up and come see me okay i
don't know what happened yesterday but
maybe that's the point i don't remember
it check your current task by hitting
tab and switching to the organizer
section on the top of the screen to see
directions use the world map there
you'll find markers request locations
clients and more
yeah good old eddie he's the head of
logistics so you better listen to what
he has to say huh logistics
he'll prep you up for the job who's
talking to me
i can't save the game right now
i need a key to open the doors
the ancient enemies of short-term memory
yesterday you got so [ __ ] up that even
i forgot where the keys are who's
talking to me
oh there they are
all right i have the keys
oh nice shower
okay whatever i guess i'm good
[Music]
this game's got some polish to it
usually when i play these games they're
utter crap and they don't have any kind
of balls to them but this one's not bad
this one really does seem to have
something enjoy the curve of you
the
what the what view
hello
hi
hey it going everybody
how you doing
[Music]
excuse me
tasks available what do we have
local square do i have a map i do okay
meet eddie
hello would you like some drugs eddie
say you eddie eddie here looking good
great
sit down i'll brief you up i'll sit down
right here
is this me sitting
sit
hello
doobie
dooby doo no i don't do drugs thank you
suit yourself
that's how i'd be drug a free listen up
i'm your main and only contact in the
cartel
anything and everything considering the
business in and out goes through me
from now on i'm your daddy your boss
your [ __ ] wife all in one person
convenient dope you write to me
you got the cash for the cartel i take
it you [ __ ] your pants i need to know
before you change your underwear
straight forward okay that's gonna
happen a lot grass and amp there are
three packages waiting for you in a dead
drop at the back of the supermarket grab
them go home and get your laptop
there'll be clients writing you soon you
make them sales and i'll get back to you
soon after questions yeah questions what
happens when the guilt gets overwhelming
and i want to turn myself into the
police trucks through a laptop shady
calm it's an encrypted app uh-huh
cartel's in the 21st century now baby
totally safe um what's it do you're a
smart boy you'll find it
anyway get to work gotta go we'll get to
you later okay thanks daddy mommy wife
all right cool just in case you're
wondering dead drops are hidden drop
points where you will retrieve smaller
packages uh trash bins hole in the
ground a big crack in the wall you name
it
they're usually marked by some kind of
symbol oh you should find it pretty easy
i'm gonna make myself a nice cup of
coffee
uh uh dad mom wife husband um do you
know of any drugs that make me have
voices in my head i'm still crouched
down just wanted to look at your ass if
you could tell me about which drugs
might
be inclined to do that dead like [ __ ]
fried chicken over and out [ __ ]
okay all right i have a task available
i'm not sure what that is
yeah the dead drop okay first package is
over yonder at the dead drop wherever
the dead drop is
perfect amphetamine and marijuana
popular and light smoked drug mid strong
and fairly addictive speed drug
put those in my left and back i got i
can't get them confused the amphetamines
are in my right back pocket and the mara
joanna is in my left back pocket all
right now go back home and get to the
computer
your first client should be messaging
you any moment
okay get notifications on new messages
on your phone but to read them you'll
need the encrypted app on the laptop ah
handy
interesting this is this is surprisingly
intricate
like i don't know why i doubted it maybe
just because all the other simulator
game that i played in the past have been
really really crappy
i mean fun but
crappy a special fantasy dark web
communicator
this is where you order the merchandise
from eddie okay this is where your
clients will contact you okay it also
has other options but we'll get to that
in time okay
you got it uh carol white
johnny antonopoulos bartek crash i'm
looking for ganja need 3g you sellin
carol
carol please
okay i can sell i trust carol okay carol
send a uh
confirm current order
and then johnny antonopoulos
you got it baby working it out in
contact
dope
okay you
i cannot decline apparently how much
a grass do i i have enough grass
oh god oh god oh god okay i can get
everyone something okay
you got it baby
i'm coming bartek
you might need that sexy red backpack on
the cupboard
i know you're probably used to those
[ __ ] casual games where money stored in
a magic cloud under god's [ __ ] pillow
but it ain't the case for us here you
need space to carry cash so take that
into consideration before you run those
first clients okay
hold be the throw backpack oh if i'm
like running away i could throw whoa
oh interesting i could chuck
that's a good idea this is this is
this is fun
i'm in
[Music]
hi
are you looking for some drugs you are
finally got here got the stuff
yeah here it is you wanted amphetamine
there you go
except you got the money
cash received and did i tell you
backpacks have downsides as well of
course they do the more you carry the
slower you run and big beefy bags
may seem suspicious to the police of
course they would
why wouldn't i told you now that's your
problem now that's my problem
is jumping over fences at every
opportunity suspicious
social 0.420 hi carol
would you like some weed you're the
dealer got the dope oh you know it
better not be a cop how do i only get
one
over ah okay alt
drag ah
there you go
much respect carol you have a lovely day
remember to order your drugs from
m-a-r-k-i-p-l-i-e-r all right excuse me
hopefully help help
bartek
bar tack you in this abandoned building
oh bartek
oh did you order the weed
yeah did you have a face transplant
something's wrong with his
face you seen what i'm seeing so did
this man cut off someone's face out and
put it over his face all right you just
made your first few sales i made some
money great i'm on my own don't look at
me that way bartek i will destroy you hi
want some drugs hello would you like
some drugs
you smell like you could use a hit of a
drug
skill point
i can expand my pockets i can grow more
pockets something tells me running is
probably going to be good it's like
percent chances the police won't find
drugs in your inventory one search
salesman okay quick learner uh
experimental points game for sales and
quest well that seems good because
that's like giving continuous returns
right
why not be a quick learner huh
all right check the gas station for
powdered additives order more dope from
eddie at shadycom this is
this is dope as hell this is quite fun
i'm having a
good time selling drugs
and now that quote exists on the
internet forever ew
hey you got any powderable additives
you're doing business behind a box with
your disgusting feet can you please put
your
amy listen
hi amy
hi so guess what my mic was muted i went
away and i came back i had to take a
small break and i forgot to turn my mic
back on
so i'm a little bit ahead i'm now an
established drug lord i just ordered
some more drugs i have to go get my
drugs i've learned how to cut them into
pieces and be able to sell the more
drugs i am an expert at the drug dealing
now so all i have to do now is build up
my respect so that other people on the
street can uh get drugs from me and then
i sell more drugs
also i got arrested by the police but
you didn't see that
run run run run [ __ ] run
he's getting away
he's running away
well here you see that but there's no
audio from me talking about it so it's
really as if i had
not doing that
all right anyway i'm gonna go cut this
drug into more drugs actually no i'm not
gonna cut it into more drugs i'm not
gonna add anything i don't actually
remember what you saw but i'm not gonna
add anything to it because it seems
cheap but you guys probably don't know
what this is i have an amphetamine jar
and i have a i should make the big one
the weed jar
weed jar i'm gonna package contents do
this two of the two gram things
got that that's in my inventory i'm
gonna package contents
i'm gonna
get
three two grand two two grams okay and
that's how you divvy things up into your
inventory so now my inventory i have two
i have three two grams of amphetamine i
i should probably also get more
marijuana
man i'm talking like a pro i'm like a
pro drug dealer
anybody want some drugs
hey you need amp of course i'm selling
carol yo mama it seems like a fake name
also there's a whole dynamic of respect
and different territories and police
patrols and all this stuff that i'm
gonna navigate like an expert
but first i gotta get my good pal bartek
bartack is that you bartek bartek the
drug man what do you want
you got it
oh that's the good stuff and by good
stuff i mean money i don't do drugs
myself never do drugs
oh my god
hey what's up pal
you wanna hey
i have a free present for you man i've
got a free present you ever uh you ever
do weed hey it's carol yomama
you're not who i gave a free thing to
who the hell are you
[Music]
there you go i guess i could just go
over
to these different new areas
and i could give free samples out not
that i would love to just divvy up all
of my [ __ ] oh i can buy spray paint now
okay so this is the other objective that
it wanted me to do and wanted me to
spray paint on walls
hi yes station any gas station
you and me both buddy we're just jogging
just jogging
hi amy schrader
how are you
okay spray paint
apparently i need this
just one please
oh 19 i thought oh i thought it was 200
oh i'm an idiot okay whatever well i'm
just gonna buy the one then i thought it
was 200 it was 200 quantity i'm in
dumbass
i'm so stupid i'm gonna go spray on a
wall and that's gonna increase my
respect
are you
[Music]
running i don't have anything on me i'm
just gonna go clean up some of this
graffiti
i sure wish that people would take this
city more seriously in terms of its
cleanliness
it seems as though there's a problem
with crime in the city and i should be
rectified immediately
boy you guys are right by where i need
to spray but that's okay you guys have a
lovely day officers watch out for
suspicious persons
you can see it in their eyes their
intentions
this playground is ripe for my tag
bruh bruh
nice
that gets me mad keep in mind gaining
respect is one thing keeping it is
another i know respect in neighborhoods
slowly drops in time
so don't forget to keep those sales
flowing of course lower suspect is less
sales less sales is less money and less
money is
well just sucks okay it just sucks we
all know this it just sucks i get it i
get it my friend
all right but there's there anyone that
wants to buy anybody want to buy some
drugs hey ben poopoo you need an
amphetamine urgent okay
fat okay you got it
weed okay you got it no problemo
everybody i have two of fett and one of
weed okay johnny
johnny on the spot
hi johnny
there you go
was that a police
carol
where are you
carol you got me in trouble before
marijuana for you
[Music]
hey how's it going take some of that
that's the good stuff
that's the best stuff actually
all right
job done
i'm shaking why am i so shaky is it the
train or is it just my hands from the
nerves of selling no it's the train
i thought that for a moment i might have
regretted everything that i was doing
mark the territory oh spray four
my ah but i don't even have four
i gotta go buy more uh
i better at least take a free sample
it's surprisingly meticulous in a good
way i i actually like it it's kind of
fun it's just
well put together
it's smooth
it plays well it's responsive it's kind
of it looks obviously it looks a little
janky but
honestly it's not bad i might as well go
do everything else i need to do
no one look
don't be looking i'm peeing i'm peeing
on this wall in the shape of a smiley
face
that's all i'm doing
oh hey you want a free sample my dude
hey
how's it going pal
how about a free present you want some
of this great
take that
enjoy it
[Music]
people are going to look at that and
they're going to be like holy [ __ ]
whoever made that
badass hey who are you stranger
get a free present for you
take some of that you enjoy that you
enjoy that now i don't know the
intricacies of avoiding the police just
yet i've been spending all my points on
learning fast i'm a big nerd i'm the
nerdiest drug dealer there is let's get
three just in case
okay thank you goodbye
clean your feet please
here we go
okay and with this
my legend grows uh yep i am the best
that was a lot of experience for just
spraying on walls unless that's not a
lot of experience and i have no idea
what i'm doing hey
i got experience for questioning the
reality of my situation
you ever think that you might be in a
video game
no
no oh i should take a or your package
waiting for you supermarket i already
got that
but i should probably pay him
i'm gonna pay you i guess if i have to
hi eddie hi eddie hey darling hey sugar
how you doing what's up babe
thank you
i think i need a little more respect
here before i can unlock the other place
which is i'm pretty sure my objective
yay
max respect somehow i don't know exactly
what i did to do that but i feel
respected everyone knows my name somehow
from my spray paint okay
let's see can i unlock no
dear litter level four you say okay
three more drops three g
of ganja
two of ganja
[Music]
speed
is that is that amphetamine i'm guessing
i'm really showing my ignorance here but
i'm guessing that's what i'm talking
about so i need who of you wait i have
two of you on me yes i do so i need a
three and a two of you
i need a three
and a two hi carol
oh
i'm level four now
oh yeah
let me go ahead and spray some respect
under the walls here i wonder if i could
break into other people's houses
probably an easier way to make money
than just just to steal it from others
but you know it's not a morally correct
way but maybe it might get me mad
respect from ben poopoo over here
hey bamboo you respect me right just
like i respect you uh here this is how
much i respect you
all right great have a lovely day carol
yo mama
[Music]
know
how are they gonna know they're never
gonna know okay but at least now i can
unlock that other part of the area
yes i know shady oh stink i don't want
to get a stink why would i want to go to
stink why is this locked this is right
next to me why is that locked oh points
quick learner again pretty good quick
learner
it's probably the best i don't know it
just seems right i could be running
better but you know i'm never gonna make
it from running away oh gain a first
dealer from a satisfied long-term
customer gain a first what a first
customer i don't know what that means
i do not have that much weed
i am sorry i need to order more but i do
not have much more i'm going gonna order
more i'm gonna max out on my weed bros
oh my god you could order so much weed
okay
where is it
what
oh oh oh oh oh oh
sweet
okay who wants stuff
4g weed 4g weed 2 4 g's
i can't do four how do i do four do i
gotta give a bonus how do i do four
oh i guess i could give two two packs
right
so technically that
that also works right that makes total
sense why wouldn't i just do that i can
count
i know how to add oh i'm very dumb
bartek
and then analogous oh god the police the
police
[Music]
okay now i'm gonna go over to the old
market and i'm going to
give out a free sample because that's
smart and i have
nothing i have nothing to do for free
sample so i'm not smart at all i'm
actually incredibly dumb it would be
better to hold on to one gram
to give out as a free sample as opposed
to two grams um interesting
one
let's give two one grammy things
excellent
[Music]
you can keep some of your money on your
bank account there are a few atms in the
ghetto where you can withdraw or deposit
cash you will need bank account money
for furniture shopping and hideout
renting
so eventually when i want to move up in
the world i have to do that ooh spray
paint free spray paint you can just get
free spray oh i didn't know that
oh
that definitely means that i could
probably break in somewhere
that definitely means that there's a lot
of doors here that are locked i bet that
i would be able to do such a thing
as that
shady
log into bank account oh my god i have
money social security hell yeah your
last salary [ __ ] you you lazy piece of
[ __ ] oh i didn't know i had money give
me my money
how do i get my money i got to go to an
atm don't i damn it donald zapkin i'm so
far away
okay speed and weed speed and weed you
say speed and weed huh i'm gonna try
something else and try something else
okay i'm gonna get this for just in case
but i'm gonna go get some lockpicks
right because i'm wondering if there's
more to this game that i have to explore
for myself in terms of
finding the true way to get things
moving in the industry that i'm in also
kind of [ __ ] that there's a curfew
just gonna say that kind of [ __ ]
yeah can i get um some
bobby pins
i'll just take 10 please
thank you
so i cannot
all right well you live and learn and
then you get loves i guess i i freaking
didn't
i guess i can't i wanted to but i
couldn't i guess i can't i guess i can't
i'll put these in my
goody bag
three speed two weed two
speed so total of five speeds
two wheaties okay five speedys two
wheaties got it just the price of doing
business i suppose maybe i could keep
the i'm gonna keep the mmm i'm gonna
keep the
i'm gonna keep these bobby pins on me
just because maybe when it gets down to
like police hours that's when i'm able
to do something like that
maybe ooh atm why they gotta be all over
the place like that
oh no i don't i didn't bring free sample
heck here
i did bring free sample
thank you hello yes
okay there you go i'm gonna go to the
atm i'm gonna pull out all my cash i'm
gonna use it to buy drugs not a
furniture place what the hell would i
need a furniture place for that's closed
apparently
okay now listen up
carefully
the bank account is the place to keep
your legal money you can use atms to
withdraw or deposit cash but be careful
huh and keep in mind that you're an
immigrant get a low life okay too much
unregistered money flowing through that
account may lure interest of the state
and that my friend is asking for trouble
alright so keep all my cash
uh under my blanket
understood
processed properly also avoid getting
into debt
first of all you'll need that account
for some payments and second of all the
state dislikes criminals but it sure
hates debtors
okay
whatever you say man okay now i have a
lot of money so i want to make a big ass
order
i would like 30 of this
and i would like
limit why do i have a limit
is it because i need to pay oh
i gotta go pay my debt before i can get
in more debt but whatever that's cool i
guess hey eddie by the way i [ __ ] my
pants i really need to change a [ __ ] in
a while ago thanks buddy i'm gonna go
change my pants
oh hey pal hey how you doing friend boo
hey would you like some uh drug
excellent you love that
what's up something different this time
thought that maybe you're looking for
some help in distribution would be
awesome to work for you
really
bartek okay you know what
i'll hire you as a dealer
hell yeah you've just hired your first
dealer hell yeah dealers order the dope
just like any other clients but a lot
more progressively
the thing is that they pay up after they
distribute so take that into
consideration
all right sounds good
all right 4g okay so i need a total of
eight ganja oh could i make these
deliveries before i get to the deadline
there i think i could i need eight total
oh
my good i'm level five that's great two
please
add the inventory please i gotta go
let's save [ __ ]
uh
johnny antonopoulos is right here what a
hero thank you
thanks bud
and boo boo
and boo boo i see you
ben poo poo
all right good good good
dominique borgington jenkins god damn
you why do you got to be so far away
oh hey i don't have any free samples
right now oh why are you gonna be so far
away dominique
i don't have oh this would be the time
to have free samples but i do not have
any time for free samples i've got good
hard-working paying customers
that are dying for their marijuana
perfect excuse me while i spray
oh look at all these freebies
i have nothing nothing
i have 688
wait wasn't i getting a drop oh i
haven't gotten the drop yet
okay
vent shaft sure
you gotta go get it go
that shaft what does that even mean i
can't see
where's my light
vent shaft
what do you mean vent shaft
oh vent shaft
oh that's a lot of stuff
i gotta go i gotta go gotta go gotta go
i am loaded to the tits
i'm loaded to the tits all right sweet
is that a message from my boy
14g of speed you got it man 14 g coming
oh god
oh okay hang on
14 g so 10
and then twos
okay
can't fit what do you mean can't fit
this is oh it's all my weed uh that's
right all right um hang on it's taking
me a little bit i'm the controls aren't
super in my brain just yet okay new
please
great and then
two twos please literally all of my
amphetamine that's fantastic i thought i
had more no yeah that is literally all
of my amphetamine okay but it's police
hours right now so be very freaking
careful me i say to me all right bartek
you better not screw me you better not
screw me man
bartek if you screw me i'm gonna
i'm gonna get you
yep clients are waiting yeah i know
no not that many
okay and
good to go
all right you go do that and you give me
my money if you don't give me my money
i'm gonna put you in stink
you don't want to go to stink
you definitely don't want to go to stink
ooh i leveled up uh looks like i'm
upgrading quick learner as usual
nice right i gotta go to the marketplace
and i gotta hand out some freebies
i just gotta be very careful
hmm
hey
you want some drugs yeah anybody want
some drugs
anybody god damn it no one wants any
drugs
[Music]
okay
all right well that was a bust uh not a
bus by the police but a bus by my own
ability to do anything which is
apparently very low okay but at least
maybe i could make some deals oh [ __ ] oh
my god everyone needs three three
i literally don't have that much
why are you guys all addicted to speed i
can't i don't i don't have that much do
i
i've got
2 grams in there i have 2 grams i
literally have 2 grams you guys are all
gonna have to wait
i need to pay off my debt so i can buy
some more i need to deliver cash oh all
right uh we go again deliver cash i'm
gonna get caught i'm gonna get caught i
know i
am gonna get
caught i'm gonna get caught
i'm gonna get caught
so long as these a-holes do not turn
around
i am so stealthy
oh more over there
okay that's fine
why aren't you bothering eddie
is it because he's your daddy mommy
husband wife too
oh
don't like that hi eddie hi i [ __ ] my
pants again
there you
go addict at least five clients to your
product that doesn't seem like a very
more oh hey bud that doesn't seem like a
morally responsible thing to do
uh but you know all's fair i guess in
love war and drugs and apparently i need
to get so much of fetimen
make new order for amphetamine
oh my limit has increased can i get 40
grams of this please
i need 40
apparently
time to go get 40 grams
what do you mean
what
what do you mean what do you mean i
failed it i have it what do you mean i
failed it
you lying to me
i literally don't know any of the
stealth mechanics so i don't know where
danger is but i've been caught before
and and i wasn't exactly that close
although i was in the middle of doing a
deal so you know that was probably what
got me there
anyway i've got a lot of amphetamine
okay i got 10 2 and 4 of 1. and
apparently this is the good stuff so i'm
going to make some deals
for phetamine
spleed speed
okay four three and two i can do all of
these and i can do this
in the middle
of the night okay here we go
okay first deal first deal first deal
first deal first deal
nice carol carol yomama
carol yomama
carol yo mama there you go
johnny antonopoulos my boy
okay
ma man
when is my guy gonna sell
donald kipzabs again
donald kabbas again
casbaghz again
bilbo baggins
yeah i got what you need
okay good
all right that's money in my pocket
that's very good
i'm doing great i got mad respect
and uh you know
i'm just a contributing member of
society and i'm doing fantastically and
if i could just get a whole
oh
hi johnny antonopoulos
yay okay good we did it
oh that's surprisingly stressful okay
just gonna save my game all right so
anyway i've been playing this for a
while um mostly because it's actually
enjoyable or like i find this oddly fun
weirdly enough
it's it's
fun i like it the subterfuge
the espionage the risk i love it all
it's very fun so if you want to play it
link is in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching uh if you
want to see me rise to the top of this
career um i don't know maybe for a
stream sometime i'll just play this but
yeah no it's kind of like you get in a
rhythm just like slow grind to
eventually i can see where the top would
be just like a lot of progress could be
very fun so thank you and as always i
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you